I'm Trevor Phillips this is Common
Ground where each week we look for
agreement on a hot button issue dividing
the nation tonight
institutional racing racism is a problem
all over
the UK it's a problem
and it's in Buckingham Palace of the one
person isn't responsible
panto may be coming early this year
complete with eggs thrown from the cheap
seats the drama roiling the land tonight
is this was Megan right about the
monarchy
The Duchess of Sussex maintains that she
fell in love with a prince but instead
of entering an Enchanted Castle was
dragged into a swamp of snobbery and
racism her supporters say she's the
victim of a brutal briefing War waged by
the old guard at the palace
Megan's kind of critics say that she
never really got her head round the role
of a princess and should have failed the
audition
a choice tonight
how should Megan be cast sad Cinderella
or scheming ugly sister or perhaps the
reality is more complex than a blunt
archetype in the next 30 minutes we go
in search of common ground
[Music]
with me tonight the broadcaster and
former Royal correspondent Jenny Bond
the actor and director kalechi Okafor
and Tessa Dunlop historian and author of
Elizabeth and Philip a story of young
love marriage and monarchy thank you all
let's first of all agree that we aren't
family therapists here in this
discussion I'm more interested in the
conduct and the future of the royal
household as a major British institution
now the Duke and Duchess of Sussex say
that the institution did little to
protect them against media intrusion
they were belittled their family was
subject to racial slurs so let me start
by asking you all in the light of the
latest controversy over remarks by Lady
Hussey what we've seen of the upcoming
documentary by the Duke and Duchess
um are they wronged or are they just
plain wrong Tessa
I think it's non-binary insofar as I the
the way it's cast in our media in
particular and by the way then projected
all over the world with our headlines
surfacing in countries where it's it's
not comfortable viewing it doesn't look
good on us as Brits this is our one of
our most famous National institutions
it's not about are you Auntie Harry and
Megan or Pro Harry and Megan you're
right it's much more subtle and complex
than that but what's happened is a
deeply emotional unhappy couple exited
an institution that was proved not to be
fit for purpose and that is a travesty
given just how important they are to as
I mentioned our Global brand they were
found literally sleepwalking and we're
going to be paying for this for some
time together
um do you agree that it was really more
a problem about the nature of the
institution than about the nature of the
people who entered it definitely I think
that the monarchy he is Antiquated it's
outdated and the practices are really
Draconian and yet we persist in trying
to keep up all of this Pomp and and and
all of these ceremonies and I and I want
us to maybe take some time to think
about the fact that maybe Megan was the
perfect person to enter that institution
to show us the things that we should
have noted much early on in terms of
like the history of the monarchy and
everything else I think that they saw
what you know they made basically made a
macrocosm of the microcosmic-like things
interactions that we have in the
day-to-day in Britain so I'm not
surprised let's let me go to Jenny what
do you think about that Jen you're being
closer to the household for longer than
the rest of us what do you think about
kalichi's um analysis that actually what
happened was for whatever reason this
marriage showed up cracks and problems
that existed in the Royal household
already
uh well I think caliche is right she was
the perfect person to enter a modern
monarchy and she was fated as such and
welcomed as such when she arrived in her
new Royal life
um I do think that obviously there is a
hierarchy which uh Harry has now
suddenly discovered of course is a
hierarchy there's a hierarchy in every
big firm every big institution and I
think therein lies the problem I don't
think uh Megan understood that she was
not only marrying into a family she was
marrying into an institution and into a
firm and in a firm that is a chief
executive and I think it came perhaps as
a bit of a surprise to her that she was
not going to be at any point the chief
executive because she was a very and is
a very independent uh forthright
um mature woman
um of strong opinions and all that is to
be lauded but it is a difficult fit in
an institution at the College of these
things existed for a thousand years
um do you think it's possible generally
suggesting that
um The Duchess of Sussex simply didn't
understand what she was getting herself
into I think it's really interesting the
way that when we want to regarding Megan
specifically we give her all of this
kind of scheming uh capacity and
capabilities I notice it with the
British press right but then on the
other hand then it becomes this whole
thing of well she just didn't understand
so if we're going by this argument that
she didn't understand then why so much
vitriol why I think you make two
interesting points one I don't believe
she did understand or she chose not to
but I too take issue with the vitriol
especially the vitriol meted out on
Megan by
older British white men it just is weird
to Bow up his Morgan they never stop
banging out let's get steady on I mean
I'm so sorry
yeah but some of the people who've been
most interested in this have been women
columnists but uh where I think there is
uh an inevitable Gap and there was
always going to be a problem she was
much older than standard consults even
comparatively with say Prince Philip who
was in his mid-20s and unlike him he was
the foreign Prince he was also very
beautiful and people were very worried
he was a fortune Hunter and foreign but
the difference was he was part of the
farm he was Queen Victoria's
great-great-grandson Megan came from an
entirely different world and people try
and compare her with Kate Middleton when
they're chalk and cheese Kate Middleton
came from an institution an English
public school you know arguably the
perfect petri dish to become the next
princess Megan comes from a very very
different world and key is that there is
no one like Megan in the household what
is going on the head of the Commonwealth
and there is under the 10 of Buckland
Palace staff
ethnic minority like someone like
caliche for instance where is that
caliche I want to come I wouldn't be in
the house yes
job application registered
I want to come to this point about uh
about race but before we do that what do
you think about um Tessa's Point here
that
um you you said that she arrived she
wanted to be chief executive or she
didn't realize she wasn't going to be
chief executive
um is there something in this that this
was a woman who had had a career she'd
already had a marriage all of that that
actually she was unusual if I can put it
that way for a royal bride at this level
yeah and that's why she would have been
so brilliant and that's also why I think
uh William did counsel Harry that
perhaps they should take a little longer
I think William gave Catherine who you
say came from a very middle class upper
class background gave her 10 years to
get used to what she was getting herself
into
um and they even had a little divorce
before they got married so she was well
aware of what she was getting into but
you'd see um Megan was was welcomed by
the queen within a few months of their
relationship certainly within the first
year
um if you're going to make the
comparison with Catherine and she didn't
even meet the queen wasn't introduced to
the queen until she had known and been
going out with William for about six
years so the comparisons
um are unjust I think Megan was welcomed
and the palace went as far as they could
to make her life easy they persuaded
Samantha Cohen who was the private
secretary who's the queen very
experienced young woman a lovely woman
I've known her for years
um and very much in tune with that
generation Megan's generation and they
persuaded Sam to stay on and help Megan
uh with her new role in the royal family
um I think they honestly bent over
backwards to do what they could but this
is a fair point though isn't it I mean
lots of people by the way including
myself uh when Megan first appeared on
the scene wrote adulatory pieces saying
this is what's going to change our idea
of what royalty is going to be the
palace itself briefed out how fantastic
this was and so on it wasn't as though
everybody went oh sniff where is she
coming from is that yeah I think that's
so interesting that you bring that up
because like I in this country
especially with who we currently even
have in terms of Premiership
representation politics really has Us by
the throat we really think that maybe
because somebody's a bit darker or you
know of this gender or whatever that
we're making progress how do you how do
you do that how do you Guild such a I'm
gonna say say it a depraved institution
how do you do that how you how do you
modernize something I've
working as a child of colonized lands
like you can't convince me otherwise
about this but we're here to find common
ground right right but so my thing is
that from the beginning as much as um
everybody was excited I was one of the
people that was like I'm not excited
because I see where this is going and
sure enough the tides turned and I would
like people to point out to me the exact
point where it turned what did Megan do
because I don't think she did anything I
want to move it away from Megan because
that is
in a moment
actually I think college has got an
interesting question there that can
either of you identify the point to
which uh which to tight turn Jenny
what what happened I'm hoping very much
that Megan is going to do exactly that
in the documentary I mean they put out
the trailer teasing us
um I suspect it was when stories started
to emerge uh that she wasn't happy in
her life at the palace and suddenly
there was some criticism of her and the
beginning as you say Trevor we all wrote
and spoke
um in glowing terms about her
um but as soon as there was any
criticism I assume that's when she felt
the tide turned for two weeks but I
think there's a couple of points the
first is there was way too much stock
riding on Megan as you make the point it
was like counting by numbers oh first
black coin my goodness first of all see
first American she was put up on such a
high pedestal there was only going to be
a crash I felt like I had my heart in my
mouth watching that wedding even the
imbalance in the in St George's Chapel
her mom versus the entire royal family
and all the yeah I mean not that that
was the Royal Family's fault but it just
felt to me me like the Princess and the
Pea in many respects something somewhere
was going to be crushed but but I think
a a bigger point is that we look and
think where where did the Tipping Point
come where was the problem actually this
is almost more about perception than
reality yeah it was something they felt
it was something she picked up the whiff
of the the way even she was an exotic
woman yeah but this is why this is why
it's important that we don't move away
from Megan exactly what Tess is saying
though is why we don't move away from
Megan because this happens to black
women all of the time black people all
of the time within the UK where it's
it's so subtle it's so Insidious when
things Dynamic start to change and and
shift around you that to articulate what
is wrong makes it difficult and this is
the nature of racism it's not meant to
be this thing all of the time that's
overt that you see it and that's the
problem a lot of people think racism is
purely somebody calling you something or
an act of visible violence sometimes
it's the things that kind of just Fester
under the surface and that's what Megan
experience I understand the point let's
let's uh address it this way Tessa
had Megan been you know a Hollywood
actress maybe not top A-list but you
know well known and successful I think
we can okay I don't wanna I don't want
to be rude but you know she'd been what
she was but with one difference not a
person of color right do you think it
would have been any different no I don't
I think the main issue is cultural in
terms of her americanness her
expectations her set of Standards I
think also her age played a big part
when I talked about so her her
allegation which is actually that this
is all about structural racism
I don't think she's pinned it I don't
think no I think that companions the
problem no no she says that that is
entirely exactly I don't think she
blames it entirely on reason I think
that's one of her main complaints it's
not her only complaint so that there's a
legion of complaints that she's got
about breast treatment and so forth and
intrusion all of those things still come
back to the fact that she's a black
woman and with all due respect as a
white woman who has not experienced is
what she has experienced nor what I have
experienced for you to say that is not
just that if you knew how how damaging
experiencing racism can be in your
day-to-day life
just a bit wild no I'm in no way
suggesting that racism wasn't a
component part but we only need to look
at the treatment of Wallace Simpson in
1936 or I think more relevant the
treatment of Prince Philip in the early
in the late 1940s
there was deep reticence the British
having had this Global monarchy in the
19th century went to having a tractor
mentality they wanted their Crown Jewel
to marry a Brit and they said so it
absolutely didn't hold back there were
calls on this Jenny what do you think
about this issue about the race you know
we had the whole story about you know
somebody who knows who said what they
said about Archie would he be
brown or not and all that stuff and now
we see in the trailer for the
documentary the issue of races Arisen
again how important do you think it
really is
well clearly it's important
um I I think though that we have to
we're talking about the institution
think of Prince Charles he set up the
prince's trust and that has helped
millions and millions of disadvantaged
young people many many of them people
young people of color uh he is a king
who would like in his coronation to be
the representative of faith not of the
faith but they won't let him do that he
is inclusive by Nation nature he is an
incredibly inclusive man and of course
head of the Commonwealth now
um and that's very important part of of
the monarchy the institution of monarchy
and of course much much of the
Commonwealth is made up of people of
color I do not think that a structural
racism within the institution of
monarchy or within the royal family I do
think they could do better I do think
there's Petty jealousies
um that have been demonstrated
um I do think perhaps they need more
diversity training but you know what I
think that is true of the BBC of Sky
probably of Big Bang of big institutions
around this country I think yeah if I
may pick up on Jenny's well I just want
to say what the full disclosure I myself
in fact was a member of the princess
trust board when I was much younger and
I had hair and you know I was able to go
out and pretend to be a young person uh
so I I agree with some of what Jenny
said can I just take you to the other
issue which is um been raised uh which
is she as you say black woman let's talk
about the woman part
um and coming back to what you said
Tessa right at the very beginning about
the way the Press are treated uh I mean
um
The Duchess of Sussex has made a great
deal and her husband has about the way
they were treated by the Press but is it
so different I mean Camilla uh the queen
now was literally the most hated woman
in this country uh at the end of the 90s
uh you mentioned Catherine the Princess
of Wales I think she was described as
weighty Katie uh because you know she
was patronizing all the rest of it there
is an issue here about the way that
women in the Royal Circle whoever they
are treated isn't it indeed we've got an
intersectional issue here where I think
part of it feeds into Race part of it's
about being foreign from another culture
and part of it's also about being a
woman a key component to being a
successful player within the royal
family is to have the backing of the
conservative press and the reason why we
now see Camilla as a success story in a
way that they don't by the way yet in
the Commonwealth that story is yet to
play out is because the conservative
press have got behind her that is all it
took for Queen Camilla to fly and the
the reverse has happened with Megan now
I'm not a Daily Mail editor I don't know
when or where the Nuance came in in
terms of the reporting in the
relationship between Megan and between
these tabloids but I can tell you that
as early as the the 20th beginning of
the 20th century the royal family
recognized they needed the conservative
press yeah you you hung out with what is
called a conservative press though you
reported for any for for um a
broadcasting organization whose name not
is not mentioned on Skype
because we love Jenny
um do you agree with that and if so what
happened how did Camilla I agree
something's changed how did she win that
support
um I think she's won the support by
being what Diana told me she was
actually she said to me that Camilla was
discreet and loyal and had been uh for
years and was the true love of uh
Charles
um and I I think she's just wanna won us
around with her hard work I do take
issue with Harry saying in the trailer
that the uh women who marry into the
royal family just endure pain and
suffering I mean it's not true
um look at Sophie Miss Jones Countess of
Wessex she's fitted in wonderfully and
she's very happy together let Jenny
finish her point as is Catherine
Middleton she she had a hell of a type
what current has Wessex if I seem to
remember that there was a picture of her
top list that was marauded around then
she had to give up her job that was
Catherine not Sophie but anyway so just
finish your point Jenny I'm so sorry
also Sophie you've forgotten Trevor okay
I haven't watched it I haven't looked at
enough of those kinds of places I'm
afraid Jenny
um she's very happy in her life fitted
in very well indeed both uh both Sophie
and Catherine so I don't um think that
Harry's Shoe is is right in what she
said and also um he he says that his
mother was hounded as she was of course
Diana was handed by the Press but I'm
sure you've seen the the news today that
many of the pictures showing her being
hounded in many of the pictures
allegedly showing uh Megan and Harry uh
being Zoomed In by the press all around
them in their trailer are false I mean
their trailer is full of distortions
it's very very sloppy production values
and if that's going to be the level of
the documentaries we're about to see
then yes I don't know what we can
believe I mean it'll no doubt be
discussed um furiously over the next few
days but it's already clear that in the
trailer and in what's coming there are
at the very least some infelicities and
things which appear to be pictures from
one place which are actually from
another place let me just come back and
and ask you about a more sort of
fundamental question because we're
really still wanting to talk about the
institution itself now the boss the king
now has to deal with some of this
collegi um
you were to be invited in to uh back in
Palace
and um and and and take take this as the
next bit of the job application and the
King were to say kaluchi what what
should I do because this kind of problem
keeps coming
month after month after month I wanted
to stop so that the institution can be
genuinely useful to the country rather
than be part of a soap opera what would
you be advising well I would I would
abolish but that's not that's not what
we're doing right now so we're not we're
not doing that yeah so let's leave out
could you abolish yourself right so we
put that to the side what I would say is
like let's think about the region like
the redistribution of wealth let's start
there because we talk about this common
wealth and people talk about it with
such glorification that it honestly
makes me sick because how many millions
of people even died in India due to the
colonization of you know that land and
then and all the countries in Africa
what are we praising exactly and then
I'm sorry like Jenny mentioned earlier
well you know the Commonwealth has
people of color well of course it does
that was the main reason that they could
be colonized because if we're talking
about how people were racialized and
system and nature from 1735 the whole
basis of race was to undermine us so
therefore okay I don't want to hold you
too much but there's a limit to what the
king even though he's the king can do
the king of him then what is the point
so that money what can what can you do
with the money right now
but just Tessa what would you advise
King Charles to do about this repeated
set of problems suggests I'd flip it
around and say that the Commonwealth
potentially is a sounding board a
grouping of Nations disparate Nations
that is something we have away from the
hoof of America that makes it really
unique and special
um that he could at least try and
represent that Commonwealth within his
own household so Camilla and I believe
she's a good stick okay I really do
think she's a good egg she's put up with
a lot
um her new companions Breakaway breaking
news even no longer having ladies and
waiting no more lady hussies we're going
to have companions but when I look down
the list of these Six Women we have lady
Catherine Brooke baroness Carolyn
Chisholm Lady Sarah Cheswick I Googled
all of them it probably won't surprise
you to hear that they are white and most
of them look like they were educated and
somewhere like Marlborough playing
hockey
because actually lady has his daughter
is that correct well that wouldn't
surprise me you've done even more
Googling than I have traveled Jenny
what's up my case and Jenny it may be
that you do get called in and asked for
advice but I'm not going to ask you to
reveal any secrets but were you to be
called in and asked for advice for the
king what would you suggest that he does
now
well one of Charles's greatest
Strang heads to get
sting to get them to try to sort out the
problems be it the environment or
whatever
um and I I think that's what he should
and will be doing I mean there are
reports I will have to ask Mr Lonnie
whether it's true that she has been
invited to uh talk to uh Lady Susan
Hussey and maybe to Charles and Camilla
they definitely need to
um have direct contact with people
um who feel offended in this way and
more generally
um yeah convene talk talk uh because
I've done enough talking we've done
enough talking it's so asinine no
disrespect it's so boring every time all
we do in these spaces is talk about oh
well what would you do and what would
you advise the amount of Dei that all of
these corporations and organizations and
institutions have going on nothing is
going to change and actually what you're
doing is you're absorbing people into
the system making them think that
they're going to make a change when
actually they're only helping you to
perpetrate more violence as far as I'm
concerned
I I just want to ask you as a historian
historian what happened in Hampton Park
I asked the questions here Tessa
um let me just ask you uh one last
question as a historian um
why are we talking about this the the
royalty has no constitutional actual
power why is it such a big deal it's
fascinating isn't it I was yesterday in
in Romania of all places and it was
headline news there
um it it is ricocheted right around the
world
um Britain has an extraordinary reach
and part of that reaches because of the
royal family and it reaches across
communities and generations Netflix and
and this emerging kind of Hollywood
aspect to our family the sort of
heartbeat of an ancient institution has
taken it to new generations and it's
also anomalous it is a head of state the
mother of all parliaments we are the
origins of democracy in many respects
and yet we have this unelected head of
state at its best that head of state
demands that are elected often callow
politicians have someone to bend their
knee to add it best it separates our
Pomp and power which I like and you
don't want Pomp and ceremony from
political separation the truth the truth
is that the household around it needs to
be a transparency to represent us and
that's where the failure lies that's the
thought I I think um insofar as we have
reached uh any Common Ground I have
succeeded as well as I usually do which
is not at all I think we are still uh of
the point of view that there are
problems with the household some of them
might be institutional problems that you
would find in any other big institution
any big company uh I don't think we
entirely agree on what they are I think
we maybe agree that the King has a role
now to get to grips with this take
Everybody by the Scruff of the neck I
don't think that we agree uh with
ukulele I don't think there's any
majority fault getting rid of it at the
moment but there may be some practical
things that the king could begin to do
lastly I think we will probably all
basically agree that we shouldn't get
too obsessed with the specific
personality of the Duchess of Sussex and
her husband they may be a catalyst they
may be an indicator of something deeper
but it's a conversation that's much
wider than just the individuals I would
say thank you to all three of my guests
that's all we have time for now stay
with us we'll have all of today's news
after the break
thank you
[Music]